good afternoon everybody I'm Gary
Tomlinson the director of the Whitney
Humanities Center not for much longer
the incoming director is Alice Caplan
and she's right down there
I couldn't resist pointing that out
Alice but I want to welcome you to the
the finzi-continis lecture for this
semester by distinguished journalist and
writer Philippe la soie it promises to
be a wonderful and inspirational indeed
presentation before I turn the podium
over to the introducer of our speaker we
do this Sara autumn I'd like to say a
few preliminary words the finzi-continis
lectureship was endowed in 1990 by the
Honorable Guido Calabresi judge of the
US Court of Appeals for the Second
Circuit and former Dean of the Yale Law
School and his brother dr. Paul
Calabresi
in memory of their mother Bianca Maria
finzi-continis Calabresi
she was a scholar of European literature
and a native of Ferrara she fled fascism
in Italy along with her husband dr.
Massimo Connor Bracy and settled here in
New Haven Guido Calabresi just presented
me a moment ago with a photograph he's
about five years old in the photograph
and there they are in New Haven already
it's an extraordinary photograph the
whole family with Bianca Maria up at the
top of the steps in any case she was a
scholar of European literature native of
Ferrara they settled here in New Haven
she earned a PhD in French at Yale with
a dissertation on French and Breton
historian Ernest r''l she became
professor of French and Italian at
Connecticut College then was for many
years professor and chair of the
Department of Italian at Albertus Magnus
College she died in 1982 at the age of
80
Guido Calabresi and his wife Ann are
here today right down here in the second
row and I'd like you to join me in
thanking them and their family for their
generosity
[Applause]
they remain extraordinarily engaged in
busy busy people and it's one always
wonderful to see them here in in in the
Whitney Humanities Center audience after
the lecture there will be a reception in
room 108 which is straight down the hall
behind you most of you know where that
reception room is already you're all
invited to it please do come and last
but not least I'm directed by Yale legal
counsel to read the following paragraph
our events may be recorded or live
streamed or photographed for educational
archival or promotional purposes
including use in print on the internet
and in other forms of media all
attendees and participants or parents or
guardians of minors attending the event
agree by virtue of their attending the
event or otherwise participating in the
event to the possibility of their voices
or likenesses being captured by these
means and used for such purposes without
compensation to them and they hereby
waive any related right of privacy or
publicity such as the world we live in
that's not part of the announcement but
in any case yes yes you are you are duly
announced introducing Philippe la song
will be today will be Morgan Kaju
assistant professor of French here at
Yale and it's my great pleasure to
welcome to the podium professor Kaju
[Applause]
good afternoon welcome to the 2020
Kinsey continued lecture and thank you
very much for adding this conference to
your schedule so my name is Morgan cage
I'm an associate professor in the
Department of French specializing in
contemporary fiction and experimental
literature I'd like to start by thanking
the director the Whitney Humanities
Center Gary Tomlinson and the chair of
the department of franchise kaplan for
making this even possible and for giving
me the honor of introducing our guest
this afternoon we're delighted to
welcome Phillip Lawson a French writer
journalist and cultural critic
specialized in French and Latin American
literature's he started Duke University
and lectured at Princeton University on
literature culture society and violence
named de Chevalier de l'Ordre desire a
de left by the French government
he's also the 2012 recipient of the only
Doheny price from the French Academy a
prize aimed at supporting literary
creation in 2013 he was recognized with
the journey together Award for
journalist of the year he writes for the
daily newspaper will be hostile the
magazine Vontae on and for the satirical
weekly newspaper Charlie Hebdo in
January 7 2015 Filipinos who was
seriously wounded during the terrorist
attack perpetrated against Charlie Hebdo
a shooting that killed 12 persons and
wounded 11 he spent nine months in the
Parisian hospitals Leticia Salpetriere
and Liz Nava did the great monument
which still serves as a hospital for
veterans his memoir luan book published
by galimov in 2018 recounts the attack
but is first and foremost a narrative
about the body about how the event and
injuries affected the author's
relationship to his parents friends and
lovers but also to painting music and
literature it's a book about what it
means to be guarded by police officers
24/7 a hospital diary on the split
between the patient and what the author
calls
davonne the man from before the new era
of Lou Lombardi tells his new experience
of space which he calls the grammar of
the hospital room I quote those who
entered the room had outside it less
existence than characters in the novel
once the book was closed end of quote
Lenovo is also reflection on time
although the narrator is an avid reader
of Marcel Proust he explicitly rejects
the expression time regained which is
the title of the last volume of allahö
shows you compelled you to capture the
singularity of his recovery he favors
expressions such as time interrupted mix
time and suspended time in the aftermath
of the 2015 attack many started to use
the slogan sufficiently Mareb lee during
demonstrations against terrorism and for
the freedom of the press
Phillip Lanza was in the hospital at the
time and was as he explains it not
charlie but Chloe in rolando he writes
Jessie Chloe which is the first name of
his surgeon dr. Chloe Berto loose head
of the maxillofacial surgery service at
the PTL patria and a key character in
his book the French title role on boo
refers to a specific type of
reconstructive surgery called the fibula
flap in French alum bo also means a bit
a scrap a shred oriT ater last fall
Europe editions published the English
version of limbo translated by Stephen
Randall as disturbance surviving Charlie
Hebdo Luna bow is a best-seller
anonymously acclaimed by critics and the
winner of many prizes the profes Manama
doraemon use the jury special selection
of the proven odo the pre hoshikawa
awarded yearly to both the latin
american writer and to a french writer
Rolando was named Best Book of the Year
by the magazine's Lea and Lisa
hajjabdullah
Philip Lasser is also the author of two
novels
Liz Yellin in 2011 the islands of the
title be
Hong Kong in Cuba and Lille on the urge
or the impetus in English in 2013
centered on mothers and one can not is
that his writings all rhyme
Liesl de la la Londe his lecture - that
starts with a question did I write a
feel-good book
so please welcome our guest Philip
Lawson very warmly
thank you good evening thank you to be
here so as my title is did I write a few
good book and the purpose of this little
conference is to answer it or not to
answer it before Christmas a French
literary magazine asks me to draw up a
list of my favorite feel-good books
obviously I was not the only writer whom
the magazine asked to do this I was it
was to be part of a feature of on
feel-good books when the end-of-the-year
holidays approach everything becomes
depressing and we want everyone to be
happy so we give them chocolate often
good books sometimes we obtain a result
opposite to the one we were hoping for
indigestion in the case of chocolates
and the Blues in the case of few good
books maybe that's what we were after we
don't necessarily like the people to
whom we think we are obliged to give
presents or we don't like them well give
him them the gifts that we would like to
receive the problem is that even aside
from the question of taste we are never
in their shoes I suppose some writers
would have liked to put their own book
on books at the top of the list but of
course no one did that also writers are
almost always convinced convinced that
the earth that they are talent they know
how to find modesty when they have to
however I said to myself would they
really have wanted their books to be at
the top of the list they drew up I don't
know many writers would feel proud of
having written a feel-good book it would
seem to most of them that they were
acting like priests psychotherapists or
simply charlatans in one in one way or
another a writer claims to be talking
about what people experienced sink and
fill this reality isn't intended to make
us feel good
it isn't intended for anything either
good or bad it is content to be born
grow and flow in every way possible like
water sometimes our imagination gives it
bank's dikes or dance but it immediately
overflows them often this reality
circulates in a whole
we were peacefully skating on a frozen
lake looking out of the sky like a
heroine in a Russian novel or a little
figure in a bragger painting
suddenly the ice cracks and we fall into
the hole this was not foreseen that's
what happened to me below the water is
cold and you can't see anything at the
very bottom there are huge monster that
never see the light of day you would
touch them you feel them you fear them
you don't tell them you don't know
exactly what they look like but it's
possible to describe the perceptions
sensations and feelings that they elicit
in us that they impose on us as a reader
I initially found the magazine requests
ridiculous but since I'm a journalist I
wasn't surprised because I know how most
periodicals operate they love to make
lists and award prizes especially as I
have said at the end of the year you
would think their editors had never left
school I imagine they must have been
model students or they want to sink
their readers we're like them model
students the ones who were rewarded
rewarded in my time at least with fine
books at the end of the year even if the
reports in the newspaper become their
lives the lives of all of losers the
lives of zoos will never appear on any
and variable list they themselves live
in the world of winners the one of
people were on the good list and they
know it
and they never stop doing what winners
do lecturing losers on what they have to
do
feel-good books are part of this lecture
Rekha if this magazines request annoyed
me it was also because my first question
was why ask me that was it by any chance
because they draught they saw that
disturbance was a feel-good book I began
my reply to the journalist what written
me by saying that I would ask my
physician to draw up this list in my
place because after all what they were
asking for was what they were asking for
was a prescription nothing is easier for
me than to obtain a prescription since
the attack I have been surrounded by
physicians like more years imaginary
invalid if one of them isn't the right
able to write a prescription for me
another will do it my physicians don't
refuse me anything they are attentive
generous in actions they get my
discipline and my gratitude but I had it
you know how they are at least in France
no one can read their writing you would
think they write like certain authors do
so as not to be read as if they
preferred obscurity to misunderstanding
when the patient enters our office is
because he feels sick when he comes out
and read the prescription before going
to the pharmacy
he feels stupid or illiterate
fortunately the pharmacist is used to
the is used to the physician and knows
how to decipher is your gift so I told
the journalist that if he wanted to
decipher the list of feel good books
drawn up by my physician it would
probably need the help of an expert in
virology or a pharmacist and I said to
myself saved they won't persist but
since I am a journalist I should have
known what most periodicals are like my
correspondent immediately replied that
he liked my answer and would be
delighted to have me develop it freely
but please no more than 300 words
it was write prescriptions are supposed
to be short too much medicine leads to
intoxication but what her good books was
but what we could do feel good books was
I going to ask my doctor to put on the
list and which of my doctor should I ask
my personal surgeon the other surgeon
who treated me one of my physical
therapist at the hospital in January
2015
my first Finnick physical therapist had
advised me to read down McNab's
Flanagan's run this is a story of a man
who during the Great Depression
organized a race on foot across the
United State despite difficulties and
setbacks several competitors came to
know one other one another like one
another out to do one another everything
hard ends well I quote a summary because
I never read the book if I understand
correctly this book is a optimistic
counterpart of auras McCoy's novel they
should also s don't they where
everything had ends badly this novel I
did read I also saw the film that Sydney
[ __ ] made of it
starring Jane Fonda but I didn't watch
it all the way to the end I must have
been 10 or 12 years old and my parents
sent me to bed around 9:30 the next
morning I asked my mother to tell me how
the film ended and she told me that Jane
Fonda died I was traumatized and to this
day I've never seen the film again the
novel by McNabb a former at the novel by
McNabb a former athlete dates from 1980
to that of Michael McCoy a former
journalist from 1935 I imagine that the
first novel the one I didn't read uses
the Great Depression as a historical
framework in which the experienced and
optimistic optimistic message of the
harlot the winner can be developed in
the second novel there is no such
message
the grid extracted the grid oppression
is not a historical framework my koi
experienced and underwent it directly
writers who have been on the looser side
that is on the side of an excess of
reality
don't write feel-good books they know
that Jane Fonda dies at the end
three years later the same physical
therapist resumed treating me again in
her office in the meantime I had started
running again despite my missing fibula
the one that now serves as my lower
jawbone the physical therapist told me
that she also ran with her dog a cocker
spaniel named happy one of the first
question she asked me was as you read
finnegans ran I almost say yes but I was
afraid she would ask me to elaborate
tell her what I thought of the novel
while she was messaging my cheeks and Jo
so I prefer to tell the truth and I said
I still hadn't bought it at my next
visit she gave me a copy she regularly
asks me whether I've read it it's in my
library between the books of Thomas
McGuane and those of rubber mat Liam
Wilson
- very pessimistic novelist that I have
read but I still haven't opened run
again run so I couldn't put on the it I
couldn't put it on the list that the
magazine would was asking me for which
book should I put on the list to answer
that question I first had to ask another
more specific one to which I just began
to reply what is a feel-good book it
wasn't possible to answer that question
in 300 words so in my response to the
magazine I wrote about other subjects
including a writer I like who I like woo
so far as I know never what a feel-good
book but whose works have nonetheless
greatly benefited me
Nabokov before continuing my response
here in more than 300 words I have to
admit
as you have no doubt understood that I
don't like lists they always it seemed
to be intended to empower those who make
them and to exclude or make
uncomfortable those were not on them
they remind me of our ceremonies at
school and even of the smell of the
cafeteria of the school
another of cauliflower and bechamel
sauce but not being the editor of a
newspaper
I have never dreamed of running prizes
and I have no nostalgia about school not
even effective my memories of the
classroom neither good nor bad they are
simply made Yoker and gray like the
student that I rabbit rapidly became
after middle school I was particularly
fond of dancers and troublemakers the
ones who didn't make me feel good
the feel bad guys I didn't understand
why I wasn't very smart but it seemed to
me that truth was on their side on the
side of the discomfort that they spread
around themselves and in me this
discomfort was not without charm without
danger and without loneliness it led me
to do stupid things to is isolate myself
to have disagreed about disagreeable and
unpredictable moods that were unexpected
even for me and also to expose myself to
all kinds of reporters first of all my
own I believed that I truly began to
read after this discomfort and in the
loneliness to which it gave rise it was
this discomfort that helped me to
understand a humble post Kafka and quite
a few other writers that is all my
feel-good books came to be there are
books that have allowed me to overcome
discomfort by exploring it they have
been my unknown friends these unknown
friends were guides like surgeon Tyree
the Army scoot in Indian Territory in
she wore a yellow ribbon John Ford
Western Sir John Tyree is young
but no longer as young as he used to be
his courageous ironic always reserved
the contrary of a miles gloriosus
know-it-all or a blabbermouth
he's a former Confederate soldier who
now works without scruples or agitations
for the Federal Army that his former
enemies because this was the South lost
the Civil War when I was a child I
preferred the Confederate I didn't know
anything about slavery or the deep
causes of the war if I liked the
Confederate it was because they inspired
Whitfield's themes that made me dream
and precisely because they lost
I liked the Confederates and I like the
Indians without realizing it I liked the
losers they dreamed and they had an
identity like the winners but they were
dispossessed of their dreams and of
their identity they had tried out all
the possibilities of life the worst as
well as the best surgeon Tyree no longer
has any illusions he doesn't show off
that is he has experience and he has a
sense of duty he has the lucidity and
the distance peculiar to certain
phantoms who are detached from
everything except the job they have to
do it doesn't have the violence and
bitterness of Ethan Edwards
the arrow played by John Wayne in the
sutures he seems to have understood that
the best we can do is to remain some
modest position that work and talent
have allowed us to obtain he goes off
all alone to explore the Indian
territories unknown threatening
marvelous hostile ends the territories
of Death Valley and it comes back with
information that he gives without
commentary to captain Nathan Brittles
also played by John Wayne when he had
when he is asked what he thinks of what
he has seen he smiled slightly and
answers that in my department sir
naturally Capitan Ritter's nose as we do
what surgeon Tyrese
sings and even that is right because is
the first the only person who has seen
the reality of life in this territory
and because he is intelligent but except
for one time when the captain gets
irritated he offers no interpretation of
what he has observed he is not afraid he
doesn't complain or comment or judge
neither does he say what he escaped he
returns impact labour from the enchanted
and funeral land of Death Valley I dream
of being able to conclude each of my
stories at the moment when a judgement
an interpretation is expected with these
words
that ain't my department sir the
feel-good books in my life have almost
all been servant Tyreese but I
understood that only when I am myself
returned from Death Valley with a
shattered jaw bone and wooden head
wounded hands riding behind the arrow
with my hands around his waist like a
child so I wouldn't fall my feet would
books written as he does now with me
from unknown threatening marvelous and
hostile lands sometimes they give me
information with a slight smile
something precise and mysteries that
makes me want to go to or return from
the place from which with from which
they come whatever the cost
sometimes then find they find me and
save me when I'm own deed lost in the
middle of the desert and surrendered by
Austin Indians as those who have read
disturbance know I had essentially
resurgent IRAs during my nine months of
adventures in hospitals Thomas Mann
Magic Mountain half-caff cars letters to
Molina and Marcel Proust in search of
rest time they were scouts of saviors
sometimes both at once at no time did
they give me certainties or results they
gave me neither good news
Nora happy hand they held up
glass mirrors to my own life but unlike
Rita Hayworth's in the lady from
Shanghai I don't think I shattered in
their reflections on the contrary they
allowed me to detach and concentrate
myself the help they helped make me in
part at least
Sir John Tyree of course I'm aware that
most of people most people especially
here in America a feel-good book is
something very different from the
silhouette and taciturn personality of
Sir John Tyree usually it is a book of
good will a book of initiative
propaganda it recounts a test physical
or moral that has been undergone and
overcome by the author who comes out of
it stronger happier and more intelligent
or in any case who presents himself that
way at the same time he gives his
distress readers a few tips on how to
cope these tips are easy to follow
a choice guide to survival there is no
feel-good book without a happy end it's
Flanagan's run written by a coach at the
end of the book as at the end of a play
the coach returns to the stage one last
time to thank his wife children friends
publisher grandmother cousins colleagues
country and even God without whom he
would not be 2000 obvious person he has
become and woman success along with his
customers await in short it's a fairy
tale set in a gymnasium when I was in
the hospital my companion Gabriela
I'm sorry wanted me to read to read this
kind of book because that's what she did
when she wasn't feeling well she didn't
understand how I could read for example
in search of lost time two years before
the attack
I had read passages from the novel to
her passages that were quiet funny to
amuse her and make her feel the power of
style and the absurdity of life she
didn't understand what pleasure what
could one could take in reading about
solitude
misunderstandings jealousies lies
sufferings and nasty unhappy and
ridiculous characters I didn't keep
trying what would that do they realized
from Chile but she had been living in
New York for such a long time that she
seemed to me to have lost the vital
sense of irony and melancholy in such a
hot city where everyone seems to think
it is possible in spite of everything to
survive and to survive and win real
feel-good books are probably a necessity
so she gave me several several of them
all American she arranged even for me to
meet the author of one of them a man who
had been badly burned we had breakfast
with him in a cafe in North Carolina I
had ordered an omelette because it was
easier for me to eat at this time
nevertheless bits of Haig were falling
on my trousers as he talked the future
belongs to us no I whipped my chin and
forgot it all Gabriela also sent me
links to videos in which a woman was
very famous in your country told oh she
had survived some deadly illness or
other was it an accident I no longer
remember I've forgotten her name her act
was excellent and for me terrifying it
was a kind of stand-up feel good
I don't like stand-up I had only to read
a few pages of these books watch the few
minutes of these videos to feel
absolutely depressed for me there is
nothing worse when one has been the
victim of an illness or a serious trauma
than reading or listening to survivors
tell you with a cheerful air do as I did
you'll get over it I simply felt like
tearing up the book and plugging my
computer killing the coaches or
disappearing for example into a forest
not only did these people with their
self-satisfaction they are superficial
optimism and their instruction manuals
not help me understand that I was
experiencing what I was experiencing but
I felt that if I spend too much time
with them I would become the
natively stupid since I'm a little corny
I waited until Gabriela and I are
separated separated to throw away these
books I didn't throw them away
immediately after our separation for a
year and a half they remained on my
bookshelf like forth or perhaps
talismans that I didn't dare touch I
think I was afraid they might take
vengeance on me you didn't believe in us
so you are going to fail this there's
always a threat in this kind of field
with books if you don't believe in me
the murmur you're lost as there are
other definitions of you good books
take for example Madame Bovary
Emma's use is narrated by flabber at the
day at the beginning of chapter chapter
6 of the first part of the novel from
there tells us about the characters with
guns a young woman identified with when
she felt in the chord and grew up in a
convent and in the purest romantic
tradition they were born in a
best-seller of the end of the 18th 18th
century and the beginning of the
nineteenth published one year before the
French Revolution she had read quote she
had read Poland Virginia and she had
dreamed about the little bamboo house
the [ __ ] Domingo the dog Fidel
but above all about the sweet friendship
of some dear little brother who seeks
red fruit for you on trees torres and
steeples
who runs barefoot over the sun bringing
you a bird's nest from where is ironic
as usual and maybe even sarcastic in his
work there is almost always because of
the sculpture of his sentences an
agitation between distance and wonder
between beauty and reality but in these
lines it is precisely the primary effect
of a feel-good book as I conceive it
that one reads the reverie
that brings the solitary reader closer
to the character characters is
discovering ends up creating a third
person
a person who is neither entirely real
nor entirely fictional a person who like
a patient under morphine currents the
pain of existence and intoxicates
herself at the same time a person who if
she's defenseless and without
information about the territory she's
entering about the world in which he
lives if she has not acquired Sergent I
risk point of view will inevitably be
massacred
unlike Emma Bovary I did not go to a
convent and I did not decide to kill
myself but I'm a well acquainted with
the statue of the author of Pauline Vee
the novelist and botanist Bernard
understand where it stands in Paris the
statue in a famous garden that he helped
create the Jardin de prompt it was the
first public place I went to
in January 2015 with my family and
friends when I was living in the pts and
Petrea Hospital and preparing myself
from one operation to the next for the
graft of the fibula to replace my job on
on that afternoon I had a lot one day
John my face a cap on my head an
overcoat that was too long and too big
for me and on my shoulder a kind of
handbag which with the help of a tube
sucked up the pews and her oddities that
were coming out of the hole in my jaw
the VAX vacuum vacuum assisted closure
system my brother took a few photos of
me lost in this overcoat and bandaged I
looked like a ghost at this moment hi -
I'm a third person Alf way between life
and the imagination of life but an
imagination that is determined by the
death that this life has just gone
through by the deaths that at that time
I found so hard to drive away I am
floating
I was the one who asked to visit this
garden of my childhood quiet close to
the hospital where I had to return to a
few hours later I wanted above all to
move as slowly as possible through the
greenhouses where the cactuses are I
have always liked cactuses and the
warmth of the greenhouses in which they
are found when I'm in these places
I feel like an eternal that nothing
could happen to me ever again underway
to the greenhouses
I stopped in front of the statue of
Diana understand here it is located a
few doesn't matter from the zoo where I
also went when I was a child in which
the learned writer founded I look at the
statue with pleasure almost with
gratitude it did me good why in addition
to his beauty it has one particularities
two levels set on this on his base is
chin and his hand the writer seems to be
dreaming like a melancholic God about
his creature his creatures which are
sculpted in the battle yet beneath him
he dominates them because he imagines
them but is this imagination with him
elsewhere toward an idyllic and tragic
world this world ends
in fact with separation solitude and
death back on the island of Mauritius
Virginia drowns in a shipwreck and Paul
dies of sorrow
Paul and Virginia was an essential book
for generation of readers it made them
imagine and love tragic tation it made
them believe what they were probably
ready to believe that true love is an
impossibility and a tragedy and this
fuzzy impossibility and tragedy were
precisely what fed the desire to
experience that love to experience it
all the way to the end Paul in Virginia
is certainly a feel-good book there was
a genuine enjoyment in experiencing
desperate love in soaking one's hurt
in an exotic and morbid liquor enjoyment
is not as you know necessarily
incompatible with masochistic reverie I
looked with gratitude at the Statue of
David under Satya this day and is
fortunate creators literature could
include the situation that I was reading
through and inspire the feelings that I
had decided to experience it could above
all led me to explore them
I left Paul and Virginia to their sad
fate in order to return to the hospital
and after visiting the greenhouse with
the cactuses - Death Valley and Sir John
Tyree I come now to two final questions
the evening of the day when the magazine
asked me for the least of my feel-good
books I said to my wife with annoyance
why are they asking me that
why me she looked at me surprised and
replied well because you wrote a
feel-good book didn't you you may not
have wanted to write it but for most of
your readers that's what you did whether
you liked it or not
you did them good at least that's what
they tell you still more annoyed I said
but I didn't give any receives and there
is no happy end at all on the contrary
the book ends on November 13th 2015 the
day of the attack of the buttock long I
was in Manhattan I could hardly stand I
could hardly stand up I had the feeling
that the ghosts of the Twin Towers were
rising to collapse again I no longer
knew what word I was like giving in my
surgical reconstruction was far from
finished and as if said that were not
enough I left the last word to my
surgeon who told me to put off by return
to France as long as I could
my wife replied still more calmly it's
not a ready hand but it tells the story
of a successful reconstruction of a
batter that you wedged and one you
didn't need to give receives for people
to feed them on the contrary is
precisely because you didn't give any
that you did them good I thought about
the letter that I had received that I
was still receiving there were Android
of them they now filled two world boxes
one in the cellar the other under my bed
I opened the boxes and we read what I
had been written to me most of the
letters came from patients former
patients caregivers former caregivers in
a country like France where the medical
system is still strong and socially so
important that includes a lot of people
one patient had given my first name to
the drip stand with which she moved all
around the order of our Hospital women
gave my book to their sick children of
Aspen's
so that it might accompanies them as yet
like a Vietcong and when the children or
husband died they reread the book to
find them alive you might perhaps ask
why is he talking on you about female
readers the answer is simple it is
primal primarily women who are reading
at least in France and in any case I've
read my book in the world where I spent
three months I also learned that many
patients now have a book on their
bedside tables my surgeon told me that
she sensed in this demand even complain
take care of us the way you took care of
him and to tell the truth I understood
them because I had always thought that
the attention given me should have been
given should have been the rule and not
the exception of the system that the
patients were most held out my book to
my surgeon who was I addressing the
person she was or the character on paper
she had become one reader also sent me
the diary he would I would kept at the
time that he was reading disturbance
nothing about his family life and his
private life was Eden from from me I
learned everything about his wife his
children
it's desires and conflicts I combine
with them even to bed and in their
lovemaking sentences I had written
appeared very regularly they had enter
into his life and when he had problems
in return to them not as solutions but
as crutches I was disturbed by this
journal and more generally by the
excessive intimacy of some of the
letters because so I had written an
intimate intimate book it seemed to me
that I had done so in such a way that
the writing itself put a certain
distance attempt and distance everything
it brought closer to the awareness of
readers it was an intimate book but I
hoped at least that it was not an
indiscreet book no one that authorized
indiscretion also I did not want to
allow readers to enter my life in
discreetly neither did I want to enter
in discreetly into the earth once
readers finished the books I would have
liked them to say with a slight smile
slight smile like servant I read when he
returned from Indian Territory I saw
this I experienced that that so far as
commentary is concerned it ain't my
department sir then I made my little
inventory of the novels that in France
are connected with illness trauma and
death and thus with medicine there were
of course the novels of narratives that
arose from the first world war
many French writers were physicians I
suddenly realized that in the last 10
years
two bestsellers and been set at least in
part in the world of the hospital
dautovic lamien lives other than my own
by Emmanuel Correa and happily live oh
man the living by mail email is ok
longer the former is a nonfiction book
the latter a novel the first book deals
with a two-for tragedy
that of a family whose child has been
the victim of the tsunami in Sri Lanka
at a time when the hotel was with them
and that of a woman the water
sister-in-law with the end of cancer
what connects the two stories is a
presence of the writer an active witness
to these dramatic events the second book
becomes a tragedy of family whoosh child
has been in a car accident that has left
in brain dead and was hurt is to be
transplanted into another patient what
connects these two families experiencing
a tragedy is the hospital and the graft
of the dead onto the living I had read
and like both these books long before
the attack on Charlie Hebdo but it
hadn't occurred to me to reread them
afterward I hadn't even thought about
them both relate a collective experience
of tragedy they tell how individuals
survive death or survive with death by
struggling and in Y where another by
coming together then I saw without
wishing to I had done the same thing I
had recounted the story of a man who was
victim a victim of a terrorist attack
and we fight to prove through but also
the story of various groups of family
members friends co-workers and Opa Opa
tell staff will this attack upset and we
are fighting to help him pull through
in this sense each of us had written
feel-good books what one woman friend of
mine had called referring to readers of
a manual Carroll's book men of goodwill
less than the bond voluntee men of
goodwill was precisely the title of a
series of great friend humanistic novels
published in the circus it was written
by a former physician dorama
what differentiated my book from those
of Karen Galan Cara was among other
things the point of view the story of
disturbance is recounted exclusively
from the point of view of the person who
experienced it I am sergeant I read that
I am also the one
man he put behind him on his horse and
Willie says by giving him first aid and
then by the slow gallop of the text a
little more than 20 years earlier in the
ninth in 1990 another book that had had
a great success in France welcome to the
story of Hill Ness and death connected
with AIDS every death to the friend we
did not save my life I had read it when
it came out and it had marked me
it's a funny aggressive slight angry
book in which the author who is like me
the patient is constantly in a state of
mistreat and effective war against
everyone is encouraged his caregivers is
an individual who is fighting and
graciously and without illusions to
obtain informations and rights that are
not being given him all that he thinks
are not being given him this individual
is a product of a world and a culture in
which the power of the gaze the presence
of the body and a certain paranoia
peculiar to intelligence dissolved
morality good feelings and everything
that was called humanism give that book
was thus in no way a feel-good book but
it made history Karen Karen Galesburg
along with my own came out in another
time twenty years later I think that in
some selves I did not bring any good
news but perhaps in spite of everything
they did provide good feelings that are
not found in gibbous book in those who
are marked by a violent violent and
transgressive individualism and by heads
or more exactly they brought a kind of
consolation consolation is neither
healing nor illusion nor a method
intended to make us better or simply
healthy
it's rather rough Paris it was it's a
rather rough caress
given the misery of the world it no
longer requires tongue transgression but
it does require
confidence
and to a certain extent the spectacle of
reconciliation in order to live in a
world that provides hardly any at all is
it humanistic Kerris if it is have I
really written a feel-good book it is
art form in conclusion to reply
we are seldom good analysts of our own
books I can simply say that at the
hospital without truly thinking about it
I made proofs Kafka's and man's books my
free good books books that were
returning from unknown threatening
marvelous and hasta lens they didn't
hide from me they didn't hide from me
anything they had seen but better yet
they didn't hide from me anything that I
experienced and they have rejoined
without commentary and with a slight
smile that endless territory my library
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Philippe it's my pleasure to
break the ice
I'm two questions really one is why do
you think it's women who are reading now
and the second question may be related
its you're setting up some boundaries
between confessional literature and a
kind of discreet but intimate literature
and I wonder how you conceive of that
intimacy thank you the first question I
don't know because I'm not so sure the
sociologist of literature and he's very
difficult what I do I know in Paris
there is a big subway I always take the
subway and it's a subway as in a train
you can see that at least in Paris who
is reading a book a woman most of all I
don't it's very difficult now because
really I adopt I think we will see later
when the relationship between men and
women change if into the world if it
won't change but as far as I know one
man of my age 56 I think that many women
of my generation I knew there were the
more access to interior life because
they are they had less access to private
life to public life and so they had
dysentery or 'ti led them to be more
sensible to the stories I read it is a
very desperately classical reference I
may be old-fashioned but that's what I
would be very used to know
what will happen in the regeneration
coming I hope of course just as men as
women would read we will read as you
warm the time I can check now it's not
the it is not going on it is still the
woman while reading at least in the
public spaces and the second question
I'm not sure I understood with the
separation between nonfiction and
I think he did say the only answer is
can be personal and the fact is as a
reader I prefer intimate tales and I
don't carry the fiction or nonfiction I
mean last summer I was reading reader
much and of course of course I loved it
and for me I don't make any difference
between Middlemarch and and the great
personal nonfiction book you know it's
these are characters and I actually
brought my book everything is real in a
sense that it is everything I
experienced and there is no lie at all
and I don't write in this book a
sentence about sins I didn't directly
experience but I composed it as a novel
in the sense that it is a tale with
character
and speaking about I was speaking in my
conference about my surgeon Chloe she is
now very famous character in in France
interviewed on TV and radio and so on
and it is very strange for her more than
for me because we she is she's a
character i I I created in my book which
is only from my point of view of course
when she asked she says no I'm another
person I'm not the person he described
but on the other way she knows she is
this person and now she will be as far
as the books arrive she is this person
so she she's the character and this is a
part of the special part of the
nonfiction
she is the character and she's a real
person and I can tell you it's very
strange to and from time to time me we
are together in the kind of show and I
never know - woman speaking - and we is
answering and because now of course she
still my surgeon so she's supposed to
work on me
in the moons coming again a bit and and
so of course has to kill the character
to go back to the surgeon and she has to
kill the writer to go back to the
patient
yes thank you so much for sharing your
story with us with inspirational talk
can we now define feeling good or feel
good as the struggle of recognizing
adversity facing it head-on and working
together in community doctors nurses
physical therapists friends and family
to overcome it and triumph you know one
adversity at a time as is this what
you're trying to define you're trying to
yes I think you know what yes feel-good
is that I mean it's what is important I
told it I hope at the end of the
conference is that the fact that a group
different group of persons not only
helped me to recover at the victim that
it was me it could be another one but
they helped themselves helping the
victim and that helping means they think
they hacked they talk to each other and
they change and by doing all that life
is coming back to a place where Dead was
invited and then my relate my if I am
reluctant to the idea of feel-good book
and so on is because you can never
generalize and indeed as a writer too
you can generalize an experience you can
tell an experience that is very
difficult to think that what work what
works for me will work for you or for
another one
and as a writer however and the great
reader of novel the novel is a great
novel it is really always the story of a
group of person and a group of a son in
a society but these are individuals the
the grid novel is one won't give you any
receive of the way how to recover and so
on it tells you this guy in recover this
way and it tells a story and this guy
default he felt and and this is a reader
worth to experienced this and and to
with with this after after while to to
think about his own life but he won't
find any solution in the book that
that's what there is no solution the
Reds are solution that only in one life
which is not another life thank you
maybe it sounds pessimistic for me it's
not pessimistic at all it's optimistic
it means we are free to first we are
free to read whatever we want to read
and then we are free to find our way
what happens to us in a certain limits
of course because when the disasters are
falling on this it's very difficult to
feel free but then you can fight and
find your own way to be to feel free i I
felt I found my own way strangely in the
hospital I was very it was very very
tough but I like the hospital because
for me I think I was at my best when I
was in the hospital it is it may be very
strange but I can assure you it was a
moment I had the best I can do not only
for me that for Hauser's I think I gave
it when I was in the hospital and then I
tried to get to meeting to give it again
in another way by writing but that
writing is my is my job since 35 years
so it's different I will address a
question to you that is coming a little
bit out of left field perhaps but we
were talking before in my office before
you spoke about the importance of music
in your recovery and your listening to
music and somebody giving you a gift of
well your it was Bach in particular that
you listen to somebody gave you a gift
of over 200 cantatas of Bach that's a
lot of listening and I'm wondering if
somebody had approached you and asked
you sent me a list of feel-good music
would you would you have felt the same
ambivalences and even anger about about
such a question it's a good question and
it's a good question where those answer
and
but I'll try to find the answer let's
take an example let's think about what
the one was very important to me when I
was precisely in the hospital bar
because it was like a ritual for me I
tell about that in the book I would
listen to baths most of all how do you
say tragic attentive a piano yes and
several Russians and so was it a
feel-good music I don't believe in God
but baths made me dropped not about the
fact that God would exist but that
something existed because I was really
feeling that he was through his music
kind of piece was falling in my room and
not on me in my room but in in the block
too when I when I was going to the blog
because what happened is step by step
people from the hospital I mean carer
surgeons nurses they would listen to bar
- and I tell ones that I write to the
brach and these days it wasn't like my
screwing my surgeon but another surgeon
who is now a friend actually and he put
some Bach before many asleep in the
block so I was really in the before the
operation and he told me I guess you
don't know this interpretation and and
so he had a look for him and so it was a
kind of she good music for all of us
but as it that sense to say that bra is
a feel-good music is more much more than
that is because on another way it turns
who doesn't tell you but it makes you
feel that whatever even if you are
suffering a lot and you have you are
absolutely entitled to complain it so
ever there is something in this music
that tells you that the best you can do
is to be silent to be quiet and because
there is something stronger deeper
coming from I don't know where and we
pass who is music and so and I could
really feel this because it's it's
unusual to listen back-to-back in such a
hospital in such an Hospital
people usually is a watch deal and not
good TV and I understand perfectly
whether I do that it's like a drug and
like do people in the jails in jail and
of course I think it's a very bad drug
will put you to depression but and BA
was talent so even it was a way for me
to attract to bring the nurses and
surgeon to my place because they would
like my place because there was this
music so it was feeling music for them
too I was wondering if you could speak
to the topic of satire
to the topic of satire and whether or
not that has a place in a feel-good book
or as part of your recovery or just if
your relationship to satire in general
has changed I don't understand diversity
so tr2 satire oh yes okay
satire I take advantage of you too foggy
hue from
very bad pronunciation and no I I still
as you know I'm working I'm still
working this satirical newspaper shall
game though and so this satirical
newspaper is most of all a newspaper of
cartoonists and I'm not a cartoonist but
I used to know them to lead to be with
them and to live in their mood so I
suppose if I decided to to work for them
15 years ago
it is maybe because the satire was part
of what I like in life because I think a
simply need for me and it's what I said
it's always for me because I think it
helps me to face problems and disasters
and I think really it helped people from
Charlie to face disasters these
disasters this Massacre I mean the
survivors of course and because we
always made fun even in the hospital I
was with wounded friends and we always
made fun about what happened to us and
about us as patients bad jokes I can
tell you because they were very bad and
we call that it was very this for the
therapy the book is not at all a therapy
the book is a creation that this kind of
bad jokes we had this presence of satire
was very important because precisely
satire is to laugh about what is not
funny and to turn it in a way makes it
fun that is a sense of satire
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]